[موسيقى]
يعتقد خطا ان مصطلح واي فاي عن الدقه
اللاسلكيه ورغم ان هذه الحروف المرتبطه لا
تعود لكلمات محدده لكنها ترمز لما هو اكبر
فهي شيء اشبه بعالم متكامل من الانترنت او
ربما مؤشر لبدايه العصر الرقمي لا بل ثوره
لتبادل البيانات عبر الانترنت فكيف اصبحت
هذه التقنيه جزءا من الحياه اليوميه
بدا اختراعه شبكه الانترنت اللاسلكيه
بفكره بسيطه تهدف لايقاف تشويش اشاره
الراديو التابعه للبحريه الامريكيه في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ففي عام
1942 سجل كل من هادي لامار وجوجل براءه
اختراعا لتطوير نظام يسمح لموجات الراديو
بالقفز الى ترددات مختلفه وهو الاختراع
الذي تم تطويره عام
1962 لاستخدامه خلال ازمه الصواريخ
الكوبيه هذه التجارب كانت مقدمه
عام
1971 نجاحه جامعتها في انشاء اول نقل
لحزمه بيانات اللاسلكيا دون استخدام
للكوابل او الاقمار الصناعيه حيث تم توصيل
سبعه حواسيب كل منها على جزيره من خلال
تكنولوجيا موجات الراديو فائقه التردد
المعروفه بيل
وهو المشروع الذي الو هانت وهي كلمه محليه
تعني مرحبا وكان باشراف عالم الحاسوب
والمهندس نورمان ابرامسون
بقيه الشبكه اللاسلكيه الاولى مرتبطه
بقنوات الاتصالات الحكوميه حتى عام
1985 حيث فتحت لجنه الاتصالات الفيدراليه
ثلاثه نطاقات من الاتصالات للاستخدام
الاهلي فاصبح الافراد والشركات والمؤسسات
قادرين على التواصل عبر شبكات الاتصال
اللاسلكيه
مع الوقت طولت شركات اجهزه الحواسيب شبكات
اكثر عقيدا ولكن مع ثوره الرقائق الدقيقه
تطلب الامر شبكات اللاسلكيه بسرعه فائقه
وهو ما نجح فيه فايز المعروف بابي شبكه
واي فاي حيث اوجد مفهوما جديدا في عالم
الشبكات اللاسلكيه وهو معيار دولي لايصال
الخدمه لجميع انحاء العالم بشكل سريع
واطلق عليه معياره
الاستفاده منه لتاسيس جمعيه واي فاي عام
1999 فانتشلت التقنيه في جميع انحاء
العالم
خضعت التقنيه الحديثه لسلسله من التطوير
كان اهمها في عام 2014 حيث تم التسويه
معيار زيرو دوت 1 الى اي 0 2 1 اي سي ما
ما هذا الطريقه لسرعه وتغطيه اكبر
هذه التطورات واتحدث الاتصال بمزيد من
الاجهزه في وقت واحد اضافه لتوجيه ارسال
البيانات الى اجهزه متعدده في نفس البث
هكذا ربط التقنيه الشبكه اللاسلكيه الواي
فاي عددا لا محدود من الاجهزه الالكترونيه
والحواسيب وسهلت تبادل المعلومات بينها
لتربط العالم معا وتخلق ما سمي لاحقا
ظاهره انترنت الاشياء
[موسيقى]